okay so Ryan Reynolds just came out and
said that Hugh Jackman is going to
return for Wolverine in Deadpool 3. and
I'm excited about this and there's two
things we're going to talk about in this
video first thing we're going to talk
about is how in the world did they get
Hugh Jackman Wolverine and Deadpool into
the MCU the second thing we're going to
ask or talk about is what they're going
to do with them when we're here so to
answer the first question I don't
actually think that Deadpool 3 is going
to take place in the main universe of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and I
don't think that Hugh Jackman is going
to come with him when he arrives in the
main Marvel Cinematic Universe what I
think is going to happen here is this I
think initially I think as far as the
release date for Deadpool 3 it is going
to be his Solo movie that comes out in
2024. I think he's going to debut
earlier than that what I think is
actually going to happen here is
Deadpool is going to debut in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in Loki what I think
is going to happen is somewhere along
the line Loki and Mobius and Mobius and
that one chick who is the TVA agent I
can't remember her name they're going to
end up in the fox verse in their efforts
to base basically escape from Kane the
Conqueror and presumably make their way
or at least Loki make his way back to
the main Marvel Cinematic Universe so he
can get a hold of the superheroes and
say hey here's what's going on and this
was Mobius and this is that one chick
and we gotta team up and we got to save
all of creation I think that he's gonna
end up in the fox first along that
journey and we know just from the leaked
footage in the trailer and so on and so
forth that Loki is going to be traveling
by himself and Loki's also going to be
traveling with morbius in them so what I
think is going to happen is that when
Loki's by himself he's kind of doing his
thing I think ultimately he's going to
be traveling with morbius and that one
chick I think he's going to end up in
the fox first things are going to pop
off and then by whatever man and
whatever means whether it's a fight and
he loses it or whatever the case is he's
gonna end up losing his interdimensional
teleportation device and Deadpool's
gonna find it now I think that is going
to segue into Deadpool 3 where Deadpool
in possession of this thing is going to
be like this is my ticket out of this
crappy Universe right Deadpool is going
to be us he's going to be us commenting
on how crappy the fox verse is because
all those movies were garbage except for
X-Men Days of Future Past Logan and
maybe kind of first class if you're
talking about the first part of the
movie so the thing about this is
Deadpool's
I can't wait to wait to get out of here
and then it's gonna turn into Deadpool 3
Deadpool kills the fox verse and here's
what's gonna happen like Deadpool's
literally gonna be like you know what
none of you guys ever gave me any
respect none of you guys ever liked me
the only person who ever treated me cool
was Colossus kind of and even then he
was a little bit of a dick and Deadpool
is going to kill all the superheroes in
the fox verse out of Revenge out of
petty Revenge he's gonna be like you
know what I'm out of here it doesn't
even apply to me anymore right it's
going to be the equivalent of you being
on the last day on your job walking into
the office and just pissing all over the
place it's what it's gonna be right
literally Deadpool's just gonna be like
you know what I'm out of here right like
I get to leave this place here's my
send-off everybody dies and like he's
just gonna kill every single superhero
the X-Men the whole nine yards any
superheroes who exist in the fox first
that we didn't even know about whatever
the case happens to be it's gonna be a
rip roaring R-rated good time that's
going to be filled with just absolute
Massacre and Mayhem where Deadpool's
gonna kill everybody that's what the
movie is going to be now having said
that once Deadpool transitions over to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe presumably
the main Marvel Cinematic Universe then
the question becomes what do they do
with them well outside of his solo film
which is going to basically bring him in
I think Deadpool is just going to have a
whole bunch of cameos I think he's just
gonna appear in a whole bunch of
different movies it's the best way to
spread them around to get people used to
him they can't overdo it otherwise it'll
be overexposure and people will learn to
hate the character of Deadpool but I
think they're gonna handle it
intelligently and they're going to
handle it reasonably but you're going to
see Deadpool appearing in all kinds of
different properties some X-Men
properties maybe some new Avengers
properties that are coming out or at
least the forerunners to The Avengers
with Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars and I
think it'd be hilarious if it were
Deadpool just trying to join teams and
nobody will let him on and it's like
really this is the problem that I ran
into in the fox verse nobody wanted to
be cool with me nobody to want to be my
friend and he literally becomes The
Simpsons meme right like all these
people are treating me terribly maybe
it's my personality no now it's the
children who are out of touch and like
that's it right like it's just Deadpool
just continue knewing to be himself and
not understanding why nobody wants to be
his friend and then maybe somewhere
along the line some things happen and he
ends up making a friend right but you
have like a Deadpool team up with like
Spider-Man you have Deadpool facing off
against the Incredible Hulk maybe but
like you literally have Deadpool
appearing as either a villain or
somebody who's trying to help but
screwing things up in like various
movies but still kind of being a badass
whatever it is I think they're gonna
move him and Shuffle him around the
Marvel Cinematic Universe landscape but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this short video to an end thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later peace